you know i had the opportunity to work
with the navy seals and within the navy
seals there's actually a more elite
group within the cs that's much harder
to get into you have to be a seal for
like five years before you even get into
this even more elite group
and i asked the director of training for
this group
you know how do you choose who gets into
this more elite group within your own
within your own culture and he drew uh
an xy axis he drew a
a graph from me
and on the vertical axis he wrote
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote trust the way they define
performance is how good are you at your
job right your skill set
uh the way they define trust is what
kind of person
and the way they put it is i may trust
you with my money let me trust you with
my life
but do i trust you with my money and my
wife right so
so uh
clearly nobody wants the lower performer
of low trust clearly
clearly everybody wants the high
performer of high trust in their team
clearly what they learned
is that a high performer of low trust is
actually a toxic team member and they
would rather have
a medium performer of high trust
sometimes a low performer pie trust it's
a relative scale
over
the high performer of low trust and this
is one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet
and they put huge
uh
credence in the trustworthiness and the
character of the team member over
their simple
performance metrics
in business we're the opposite we have a
million metrics to measure someone's
performance and we have negligible to no
metrics to measure someone's trust and
so you may have a selfish driven toxic
team member
um who if they're high performing what
do we do we promote them
and sometimes you get to the point where
leadership knows that this person is
toxic and you say you know you probably
should do something about this you maybe
want to remove them from the team and
they say the same thing they're like
yeah i know the performance is so good
you are literally just waiting for
something to collapse meaning either
other people will leave or the culture
will start to crack or there's a scandal
or that person will leave because they
get a better job off them they're not
loyal so they may be your highest
performer but they're not loyal
um what the what the seals learn
uh
is sometimes these these medium
performance of high trust are your best
natural uh uh
best natural leaders
the irony is you know if you go to any
team
it's actually really easy to find these
toxic team members that's the irony even
though we don't formally measure it go
to any team and ask them who the [ __ ]
is and they'll all point to the same
person
okay
um uh and and and and that that's an
opportunity to coach them i don't
believe in firing them i believe in
coaching we let people go when they
prove to be uncoachable and by the way
if you go to that same team you say who
do you trust more than anybody else
who's got your back no matter what who's
always who's always there to help you
they'll probably also point to the same
person who might be your best natural
leader and they may not be your best
individual performer